- Hello, everybody.
I'm Maurice Samuels,
the Director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism.
And it's my great pleasure
to welcome you today
to the next installment
in our Benjamin and Barbara
Zucker Lecture Series,
which is being co-sponsored today
by the University of California, Berkeley.
Our speaker is Ethan Katz.
He received his BA from
Amherst and his PhD in history
from the University of Wisconsin.
Before moving to Berkeley,
he taught at the University of Cincinnati
and he is now Associate Professor
of History and Jewish Studies at Berkeley,
where he co-leads an anti-Semitism
education initiative,
which he recently founded.
A specialist of France
and the Francophone world,
Katz's research interests
include Jewish-Muslim relations,
Jews in colonial societies,
Holocaust studies
and the interplay between
the religious and secular
in modern Jewish life.
His first book,
"The Burdens of Brotherhood:
Jews and Muslims
"from North Africa to France"
published by Harvard in 2015,
received a number of prizes,
including a National Jewish Book Award,
and the J. Russell Major Prize
of the American Historical Association.
Katz has also co-edited three books.
These include "Colonialism and the Jews",
honored last year as a finalist
for a National Jewish Book Award.
And most recently "A Special Issue
"of the Journal Jewish
history on Jews and Muslims
"in France Before and After
Charlie Hebdo and Hyper Cacher".
he's now at work on an
exciting new book project
on the Jewish underground in
Algiers, during World War II,
currently entitled "Freeing the Empire:
"The Jewish Uprising
Of Jews and Antisemites
That Helped Win the War II."
And his lecture today draws
from research for this project.
So I wanna urge all of
you to ask questions,
to write your questions at any point.
You can start writing as
soon as he starts talking,
but submit those questions,
using the Q&A function
at the bottom of your screen.
Please don't raise your hand.
I won't see it and don't
virtually raise your hand
'cause I won't see that either.
And the chat function has been disabled.
So the way it's gonna work
is that Ethan is going to
give his presentation
for about 30, 35 minutes.
And then we will open
it up to your questions
that I will filter from the Q&A function.
So Ethan, take it away.
- Thank you so much, Maury.
Thank you for the invitation
and for that kind introduction.
I'd also like to thank in NSL Cova
for all of the arrangements that were made
in setting up and publicizing the lecture.
And to Harvey at Berkeley
for her work as well.
I'm gonna go ahead and
share my screen here.
One moment.
Okay.
In the morning hours
of November 8th, 1942,
the American and British
armies began Operation Torch.
At that time, the largest
amphibious landing
in recorded human history,
the invasion saw 110,000
troops in 800 warships
and transports land on a score of beaches
spanning more than 1200
miles of the Atlantic
and Mediterranean coastlines.
The key site for the
campaign was North Africa
and all involved in the strategic planning
agreed that victory ran
through the rapid seizure
of the city of Algiers.
Now it's well known that Operation Torch
opened a crucial second
front and World War II,
soon chasing the access
forces from North Africa,
setting in motion the allied
liberation of Southern Europe.
What is far less well known
is that the allied path
into Algiers was paved by the work
of an underground movement,
in which a band of young Jewish liberals
teamed with a group of arch
conservative military brass
and businessmen.
Over a period of months
proceeding the invasion,
the resisters coordinated their
efforts with the Americans
in particular with Robert Murphy,
the special US Envoy to the region,
who reported directly to
President Franklin D. Roosevelt.
In the last days before the invasion,
the home of Henri Aboulker
became the headquarters
for the insurgency.
Aboulker was a prominent figure
in the Algerian Jewish community
and more broadly respected
as a doctor, professor
and local political leader.
His son who's pictured here on the left.
The 22 year old medical
student, José Aboulker,
had been one of the earliest
to organize resistance
in Algeria and would
assume central importance
in the insurrection.
In the wee hours of November 8th,
the designated date of the allied landing,
a rather motley group of
several hundred students,
shop owners, doctors, lawyers
and a handful of French military officers
managed to take over nearly
all of Vichy France's
major institutions in Algiers
and they placed the regimes
key leaders under house arrest.
The success of the underground
was all the more remarkable
for the numerous obstacles they faced.
The insurgents were ill-equipped,
only possessing several
hundred level rifles
that predated World War
I and tour buses provided
by the Americans.
In many cases, their claim
to authority was thin.
They had disguised themselves
by wearing armbands
with the initials VP.
The insignia of a local volunteer militia
tied to the Vichy Regime.
In the days before the invasion,
promised arms from the Americans
repeatedly failed to appear.
At the appointed time on
the night of November 8th,
at least one third of the
young men who had affiliated
with the insurgency
movement did not show up.
In the midst of chaos
José Aboulker took charge
as various teams of insurgents
fanned out to key points
throughout the city.
At a series of locations in
the same scene repeated itself.
A small group of resistors
showed up wearing the arm bands
of the local militia, carrying rifles
and in some cases they
did not know how to use.
And showing orders for them to
relieve the Vichy commanders.
Unsuspecting the officers
on duty turned over control
of each strategic location to
the members of the insurgency.
Yet as dawn broke, there was
still no sign of the Americans.
They had elected to take
a slow and circuitous path
toward Algiers rather than the rapid one
originally promised.
Now Vichy had begun to fight back.
José Aboulker utilized a
blend of ruse and inspiration
to rally the resistors,
imploring them over the radio
to hold their posts for
as long as possible.
Eventually late that day,
the allies entered Algiers
and took control of the city
without firing a shot.
Before too long,
they would control the
broader Mediterranean.
At the time of the invasion,
North Africa was under the
control of the Vichy Government.
Francz's authoritarian pro German regime
that had taken powers shortly
after the French surrendered
to the Germans in June, 1940.
In October, 1940 of its own accord,
Vichy had abrogated the Crémieux Decree.
The act that in 1870 had
made nearly all Algerian Jews
into equal French citizens.
The decree had been a turning point
in Algerian Jewish history.
Separating Jews from their
Muslim fellow natives,
who did not enjoy citizenship
and became racially defined
as so-called indigène,
which translated to natives,
but had a more negative connotation.
And this began a process
whereby Algiers Jews
would gradually become deeply attached
to French language and culture.
Now in October of 1940,
with a stroke of a pen,
Jews were suddenly demoted to indigène
or colonial subjects themselves.
They occupied the same status as Muslims.
Further anti-semitic measures followed.
Less to the consternation
of the Jewish insurgence
of November 8th, 1942,
the liberation of Algeria by the allies
did not restore Jews
pre-war status overnight.
Instead, a new battle began
over the territory's French leadership
and ideological direction.
Jews despite their central
role in the uprising
did not succeed immediately
in regaining their rights.
For the first few months,
following the landing,
all of the racial laws remained in place
and Jews who had lost
their professional position
or their property only recovered them
on an individual basis.
It was only in October of
1943, nearly a year later,
that Jews in Algeria regained
their French citizenship.
Now scholarship on the Algiers underground
and its Jewish participants
remains rather limited.
And today it has generally
focused on either the military
and political strategy of
the North African campaign
and its aftermath,
or on the episode as a
case of Jewish heroism
soon betrayed by the American invaders
and the French administration.
These analyses have left
us with little sense
of who the resistors were
and what motivated them.
More specifically, we are left to wonder
at the curious Alliance
at the heart of the story.
For the groups ideological
diversity was remarkable.
Monarchists and communists,
opponents of democracy
and argued Republicans and
perhaps most strikingly,
Jews and anti-semites joined
together in what became known
as the movement of November 8th.
How was this possible in the
book I'm currently writing,
this is among the puzzles
I'm trying to piece together.
And the focus of much of my
talk today will be outlining
the participants in this rebel Alliance
and discussing some of
the possible catalysts
for their cooperation,
that not only seems
counterintuitive today,
but did at the time as well.
I should add that this is
very much a book in progress,
and I look forward to your
questions and comments
as I continue to think about the issues
that I'm discussing today.
But before I get to this puzzle,
we can only appreciate the
history and significance
of the Algiers insurrection
by placing it within the
broader context of a Holocaust
in North Africa and European
political culture in Algeria.
Well, Central and Eastern Europe
of course saw the greatest
anti-semitic atrocities
during the Holocaust.
The nearly half million Jews
living in French North Africa
suffered significantly as well.
Many racial laws enacted by
Vichy were extended to Algeria,
Morocco and Tunisia.
Leading to severe professional quotas,
intensive surveillance, and
more than 100 labor camps.
Where Jewish prisoners
were often singled out
for especially harsh treatment.
Algeria is particularly
significant to the European story.
The territory was in large
part and next to France
since the 19th century.
And was home to almost a million
European colonial settlers
whose political culture was
steeped in the anti-semitism
of the 1930s.
By late 1941, most, excuse me,
most Jewish children had been expelled
from the public primary
schools in Algeria,
most notable and devastating
of the measures taken in Algeria however,
was Vichy's decision in autumn 1940
to strip all Jews of
the French citizenship
that they had enjoyed for 70 years.
The story of the resistance
also looks different
from the Mediterraneans Southern shore.
What we mostly know about
the French resistance
is a classic case in which
history has been written
by the victors.
The wartime triumph and
post-war legacy of the galists
and communists, helped
to create a narrative
that makes several assumptions.
First, we imagined that
French insurgents emerged
in opposition, not only to the Germans,
but also to the Vichy government.
In addition, we see the resistance
is comprised of liberals,
Republicans, socialists, and communists.
Finally, according to a
stubbornly enduring narrative,
on one side stood Lezi
staunt fighting virtuously
against Nazi and Vichy anti-Semitism.
While on the other side, stood
anti-semitic perpetrators
and collaborators.
The story of the Algiers
insurgency problematizes
each of these assumptions.
The developments that would
become the Algiers insurrection
gathered steam across three
geographical nodal points.
And the first of these was not Algiers,
but somewhat surprisingly,
it was actually Vichy.
The resort town in the
Massif Central region
of Southern France, where
Marshal Philippe Pétain,
set up the new French government
after the fall of France
in June, 1940.
As many of you know,
Vichy was authoritarian,
anti-republican,
traditionalist, pro-German
and anti-Semitic.
It was also as
counterintuitive as it seems,
an important wellspring
of early resistance.
While they remain little known,
during the early months
following the defeat,
numerous Vichy officials in a double game.
They remained loyal to Marshal Pétain,
but they mistakenly believed
that he was hamstrung
by the occupiers
and that they should
thus begin to undertake
the work of resistance that
he ultimately supported,
but could not do himself and
might openly join some day.
These were among the group
that a handful of historians
of the occupation in France
have in recent years dubbed
vichysto-résistant.
The notion of the vichysto-résistant
only really emerged
in the aftermath of
revelations in the mid 1990s,
that then French president,
François Mitterrand
pictured second from
the right in the photo
on the left here,
had affiliated for several
years with the organizations
of the far right.
And had worked loyally for
Vichy France until 1943.
This was a major shocking
scandal at the time in France.
Indeed, the vichysto-resistant
also included many,
like Mitterrand who underwent
a process of evolution
in the course of the war.
From Vichy loyalists to full participants
in the organized resistance.
The term applies as well to
those who had been members
of interwar extreme right groups,
but decided or retaining their ideology
to act against not only the Nazis,
but also the Vichy regime.
Even as they fiercely opposed the Germans
and sought to renew the
French fight against Nazi-ism,
these men and women often supported
much of Vichy social policy,
including regarding Jews.
And this was the case for several actors
in the Algiers insurgency.
In order to account for the importance
of the arch conservatives, who
were the vichysto-resistant
and played a leading
role on the insurrection.
We have to turn to the second
geographic note in our story,
Washington.
Washington's eyes and ears in North Africa
were substantially those
of US Envoy, Robert Murphy.
Who reported directly to
president Franklin D. Roosevelt.
From the moment of the
French defeat in June, 1940,
the race was on to find partners
in French, North Africa,
who might play a role
in an eventual effort
to liberate Europe.
Murphy along with other
key American officials,
took a decidedly pragmatic
approach in looking
for these partners.
Murphy and his colleagues long believed
that some version of Vichy in fact,
might be part of the solution
rather than the problem.
Eventually, the Americans became convinced
that General Henri Giraud
rather than Charles de Gaulle,
the leader of Free France in London
was the right man to lead the resistance.
Giraud was at heart,
a proud French Patriot
who believed the Germans
could be defeated.
What he sought to overturn
was not Vichy social policies,
but rather its decision to
collaborate with the Germans.
Giraud himself was
unabashedly anti-semitic.
The choice of Giraud as
leader of the resistance
highlights what would become a key pattern
of American conduct in North Africa.
A single-minded focus on winning the war
at the expense of
ideological considerations
or deep concern for Algeria Jews.
Giraud stepped into a movement
where other prominent
Frenchmen from the mainland
were also in key roles,
many of whom were equally
or more conservative.
This was particularly
true of the so-called
Committee of Five, the
group of French businessmen
and officers who work
closely with the insurgence
and the Americans and coordinated
many of their efforts.
The group included Henri
d'Astier de La Vigerie.
A committed monarchist and longtime member
of the Action Française,
immensely influential
neo-monarchist, anti-democratic
ultranationalist political party,
for which a virulent anti-semitism
was a central preoccupation,
since its founding
during the Dreyfus Affair.
d'Astier was rumored to have
participated in the Cagoule
of 1936 to 1937.
The Cagoule was originally a breakaway
from Action Française.
It was an extreme right
underground revolutionary movement,
whose long list of about enemies
and targets included Jews.
Working close to with Italian fascists,
the Cagoule stockpiled weapons,
assassinated the leftists
and planned a coup d'etat
against the full population.
Two other members of
the committee of five,
Jean Rigault and Jacques
Lemaigre-Dubreuil,
were confirmed former Cagoulel.
Rigault used his closeness
to the Vichy regime
to foster contacts
between certain officials
and the movement and Algiers.
Lemaigre-Dubreuil admired
Vichy's anti-democratic
autocratic tendencies
and its arch conservative
national revolution program
of national renewal.
And he was deeply suspicious of communism.
Both were avowedly anti Gaullist.
A fourth member of the
committee, Colonel A.S. Van Hecke
actually headed the
Chantiers de la jeunesse,
Vichy's officials scouting organization
meant in large part to
serve as a youth movement
that would acquire and
help to spread the values
of the national revolution.
Van Hecke sought to rally several hundreds
Chantiers troops within
the Algiers underground
as the work of Daniel
Lee has shown recently,
the Chantier in the mainland
did for a time offer protection
to a significant number of Jews.
Nonetheless, in November,
1941 in administerial memo,
Van Hecke made no bones about
the fact that he thought
the Chantier in North
Africa should not accept
any Jewish members at all,
because Jews he claimed could not acquire
the nationalistic values
of the national revolution.
It is a memoir of the early
years of the resistance,
Jacques Tarbe would claim about Rigault
and Lemaigre-Dubreuil.
And this might be said about a number
of the Vichysto-resistant quote.
The hostility toward
Germany was matched by their
hostility toward Free France.
A quote Free Vichy was not a free France,
but rather the national revolution freed
from the Hitlerian shackles
and protected by Washington.
This is what they wanted, and
this is what they almost got.
So Estelle's caustic remark
hinted at a deeper truth
that we can better appreciate
in light of the current scholarship
on the Vichysto-resistant.
A key contingent of the
insurgency comprised men who
even as they took great risks and joined
clandestine networks to resume
the fight against the Germans
also had links to Vichy
that continued to influence
the resistance war.
Now, the successful turn
of the Vichysto-resistant
would not have been possible
after their unlikely alliance
with a scrappy group of Algeria Jews.
These Jews emerged from what
I have described elsewhere,
borrowing the terminology of David Sorkin
as an Algerian Jewish subculture
in the wider European sector
of Algerian colonial society.
That is even as these Jews took
French first names in public
spoke primarily French in public,
often saw themselves as
unqualifiably French,
their primary community was made up
of other Algerian Jewish
individuals, groups
and institutions.
This was reflected in a number
of common characteristics
of the Jews in the insurgency.
Taking us into the third
noble point in our story.
These Jews tended to cluster
in certain neighborhoods
of Algiers with high
concentrations of Jews.
We see a marked on this map,
a few of those places in Algiers,
as well as scenes from those
neighborhoods on the left.
Moreover in many cases,
large numbers of resistors
hailed from the same extended family.
Among the Aboulker family for example,
some 15 siblings, cousins
and uncles across two cities
took part in the insurgency.
Beyond social geography
and kinship networks,
a high percentage of these
Jews came from families
that were active in major
Jewish organizations,
particularly those that
sought to fight anti-semitism
and improve relations
with the Muslim and Christian populations.
These included the major
community political organization,
the Algerian Jewish
Committee of Social Studies,
or the CJAES and the Algerian branch
of the largest French
anti-racist organization,
the International League Against
Racism and Anti-Semitism,
better known as the LICRA.
The organizational mission of
both the CJAES and the LICRA
made them logical entry points
from which to move into active
resistance during the war.
The CJAES defined its
goal as keeping vigil
in order the Jews free
exercise of the rights
of the citizen, neither be
violated nor little note.
The LICRA was an organization
founded precisely
to combat antisemitism and
whose functions by the mid 1930s
included that of having
certain members act
as a Jewish defense force.
Shortly after Vichy
dissolved the LICRA in 1940,
José Aboulker's cousin Rafael
pictured here on the left,
who had begun attending the LICRA meetings
a few months earlier in Algiers,
gathered dispersed members
of the organization
and directed them toward the newly formed
so-called Geo Gras Group.
Among the founders of the Geo Gras Group,
were Emile Atlan and Andre Temime,
both former activists in
the recently banned LICRA.
In my research, I've identified
as many as three dozen
former LICRA activists who
participated in the insurrection.
Other examples of the active
Jewishness of participants
included charity, the local
Jewish aid organizations
or schools in the years before the war
and the several Jews in the underground
who also had a role in
creating a newly self-reliant
Jewish school system in the face
of Vichy's anti-semitic laws.
Being active in an
organizations like the LICRA
reflected another common element
of the Jews in the insurgency.
The newly aggressive politics
that defined the actions
and outlook of many of them.
One of the characteristics of
a new generation coming of age
in the 1930s, which highlights again,
the paradoxical nature of
the Wartime Rebel Alliance,
was widespread activist, excuse me,
widespread activism in
anti-fascist politics.
So this is extremely
common for many of those
who took leading roles in the insurgency.
Particularly in the era after
the 1934 Constantine riots,
a new generation of
Algerian Jews joined groups
like the LICRA and became
active in large numbers
in the Algerian Communist Party.
And this marked the
beginnings of the key shift,
unlike much of the community establishment
of their parents generation,
these Jews took a more
confrontational pose,
gathering arms, standing up
to fascists in the street
and even preemptively
attacking on occasion.
And the clearest echo of
this newly aggressive posture
within the resistance appeared
in the Geo Gras self-defense group,
that formed it autumn 1940.
And that would supply in
time 130 of the insurgents
who fought on November 8th.
You see pictured here the boxer Geo Gras,
for whom the group was named.
He agreed to open this space,
only thinking that it was a space for
physical fitness and training,
whereas secretly this militia
was preparing itself there.
And became a training round
for Jewish shock troops
who would both prepare
to fight against Hitler
and to defend Jews.
And its ranks included 80 so-called Tufts,
described by resistor Lucien Adés
as muscular daring fighters.
They were ready at a moment's notice
to confront the local militias
that regularly attacked Jews.
New aspirants to the Geo Gras
Group were closely screened.
If accepted, they then took
an oath to fight to the death
for the liberation of France
and the defeat of the Germans
and specifically to defend Algerian Jews.
And there was a sense of
this generational shift
that was present for Henri
Aboulker, father of José,
who would agree to let his
home be the headquarters
for the resistance in the
weeks before the landing,
when he recounted later the story.
And he spoke about the activism of José
and his sister Colette.
Ultimately he explained
he had agreed to let them
use his home as a hub,
mostly because he feared for their safety
and sought to protect
them as any father would.
But he also admired them.
Put the quote here.
He said, "They received
no outside material help,
"absolutely none,
"and they all make great
personal sacrifices.
"At various times, I tried to
reimburse them, they refused,
"I insisted, they became angry.
"Having seen all of that up close,
"I loved them all the more.
"I was disgusted at the general passivity,
"the universal spinelessness
I had seen for years,
"above all, since the defeat.
"If I had died in 1940 or 1941,
"I would have died in despair.
"Having seen the work of
the boys of November 8th,
"I was relieved. I could die in peace.
"They furnished explosive proof
"that pessimism should be set aside,
"that there reside in our youth resources
"that are unexpected, immense, unlimited."
This generation's newly
assertive, left wing politics,
hardly aligned, I think
that's an understatement,
with those of the Vichysto-resistant,
that were of course connected
very much to the right,
yet with whom they
conspired in the insurgency.
And indeed José Aboulker and
Henri d'Astier de La Vigerie
understood that their Alliance
based on disparate goals
could only be possible,
if the movement reached a formal agreement
to avoid politics altogether,
while pursuing its common ends.
The two men did just
that in summer of 1942.
With the understanding that each group
would immediately regain its
freedom of political action,
following a successful allied landing.
Once again, this extreme
mixture of strange bedfellows
and pragmatism defies
and during assumptions
about the ideological
stakes of both Jewish
and non-Jewish resistance.
I'm gonna stop sharing my screen now
because those are at the
end of my PowerPoint images.
So what was it that made such an alliance
however fleeting possible?
Contemporary political alignments
and historical precedents
weighed heavily against it.
At the heart of the
alliance was a relationship
between two men who seemed
to have a little in common.
The young Jewish
anti-fascist from Algiers,
José Aboulker and the middle
aged French monarchist
Henri d'Astier de La Vigerie.
55 years later in an interview,
Aboulker would put it this way, quote.
"We knew that he was a monarchist
"and even probably a Camelots du roi."
And he referred here to this so-called
Kings Camelot's youth organization
of the Action Française that
frequently engaged in protests
and violence street
altercations in the 1930s.
Aboulker continued,
"Why did I reach an
understanding with him?
"Me a Jew 22 years old and anti-fascist.
"This man had probably
cried death to the Jews
"during protests in the
Latin quarter in Paris."
His comment alluded to
the way that numerous Jews
on one side and arch
conservatives on the other,
had been active in opposing camps
and the pitched ideological
struggles of the 1930s.
But it also hearkened
back to a longer history
wherein Jews and monarchists
had hardly mixed well
in modern French history.
As Maurice Samuel's new book,
"The Betrayal of the
Duchess" shows in fact,
tensions between monarchists
and Jews were crucial
to the origins of modern
French anti-semitism.
During the 1832 uprising
of the so-called Bourbon Legitimists,
that sought to reclaim the throne
from the more modern old and East branch,
Simon Deutz, son of the
chief rabbi of France
and recent convert to
Catholicism played a key role.
First Deutz gained the confidence
of the uprisings leader,
the duchesse de Berry
and then in exchange for a large reward
from the French government,
he betrayed her.
Deutz rapidly became dubbed
quote "A second Judas."
And was seen as the very
embodiment of all the evils
of modernism that the
legitimists and their supporters
so desperately opposed.
More recently in the late 19th century,
Antoine Mayal, a wealthy
Jewish capitalist,
had directed the right wing
royalist newspaper, Le galhua.
Eventually becoming an
ardent anti-Dreyfusards,
converting to Catholicism
and marrying a woman of noble
origin at the age of 60.
Mayal was heavily criticized
by Jewish activists
like Benla Lasalle for
betraying his origins
and exploiting the working class.
So there was a great deal
of baggage, if you will,
weighing down the possibility
of close cooperation
between an ardent monarchist
and a visible Jew.
And yet a series of considerations,
both practical and
ideological brought together
Aboulker and d'Astier and by
extension many around them.
On the pragmatic side, we have
seen the US State Department
decided to set aside concerns
about policy and rights
in the short term, in order to
prioritize military victory.
This meant supporting what became
a coalition of conservative,
even anti-semitic forces
and Jewish activists,
since both groups were
ready to help pave the way
for the Anglo-American landing.
Algerian Jews meanwhile had
already in the interwar years,
particularly after the
murderous Constantine riots
of August, 1934, ceased
to rely as they long had
on the French government
to protect their position.
In an exception, Joseph Harmir
Shami's well-known argument
about modern Jewish politics,
they had moved increasingly
from, to use his terms,
vertical to horizontal alliances.
In the 1930s, these were
largely with reformists
and Muslims on the left.
But after the shattering events of 1940,
the same Jews were equally
prepared to team with forces
on the right in a temporary
alliance against a common foe.
Likewise, in his memoir of the insurgency,
José Aboulker himself
points out the military,
that military and business leaders
looking for a band of rebels
had limited options in Algiers
in the 1940s.
Here, unlike in France,
where Jews were a tiny
percentage of the population,
Jews made up 10% of the French citizens.
Moreover, insists Aboulker
for those looking for allies
to fight the Germans,
Jews particular motivations
made them the surest bet.
As historian Joanna Bahaj has argued,
political flexibility was
more broadly a hallmark
of the Vichysto-resistant.
By 1943, notes Bahaj, despite
their fierce anti-communism,
for instance, they had decided
to work alongside communists
in order to be accepted
within the broader French resistance.
The instruction of Algiers
shows that their pragmatism
in fact, dated from
earlier and extended even
to an Alliance with Jews.
Ideological considerations
though, were also important.
Aboulker's supposition about
d'Astier's participation
in anti-semitic rallies, not withstanding,
d'Astier's brand of monarchism
took a more moderate position
on Jews.
He came from a family that
had supported the monarchy
for generations.
And while he retained
sympathy for the more radical
neo-monarchism of Shalnohra
into the late 1930s,
he was more closely aligned
with de León, Le comte de Paris,
and the primary pretender at
this time to the Royal throne.
In fact, in the days after
the American landing,
d'Astier even helped to bring to Algiers,
where he hold them up in his apartment,
as he sought to negotiate
a monarchaic restoration.
American general, Dwight Eisenhower,
quickly quashed this idea.
Le comte de Paris had repeatedly condemned
the Action française in the 1930s
and sought to create an
alternative strand of royalism.
In January, 1939, he had
even penned an article
in his movement's newspaper,
(foreign language)
where he denounced antisemitism
in no uncertain terms.
He wrote quote,
"It is certainly abusive
to speak of a Jewish peril
"in France."
In particular, he
highlighted the way that Jews
whose families had long resided in France
should be assumed to be good citizens.
These Jews, he wrote quote,
"Took part as soldiers,
"as officers in the national wars.
"They have mixed their blood
with that of the peasants,
"the workers, the bourgeois of France.
"They are French and
to want to exclude them
"from the national community,
"or even to deny their full
rights as French citizens
"is to wish to weaken the
country that they have served
"and that they should continue to serve."
This column was reprinted in the bulletin
of the Federation of Jewish
Societies of Algeria,
the community's monthly newsletter.
And given the level of
involvement of the Aboulker
with community institutions,
it is extremely likely that
many members of the family
and those in the wider
milio of the insurgency
would have read this article
and thus been familiar
with the more progressive
term and royalist thinking
regarding the Jews.
The mention of Jewish
soldiers specifically here,
was also hardly incidental.
Even in an infamous
statement where he embraced
Marshall Pétain and Vichy,
leading conservative resistor
Alie Frene had answered the
question of who to recruit
to the resistance by saying, quote,
"French men of old extraction
"to the exclusion of foreigners,
"even those who are naturalized.
"And Jews, if they really fought
"in one of the two World Wars."
A very high percentage
of the Jewish fighters
in the Algiers insurrection
were veterans of the campaign
of 1940, including José Aboulker himself,
who had served as an army medic.
José Aboulker would later
explain his close cooperation
with d'Astier in simpler terms.
Quote, "We had something in common
"that the generations of today
no longer are familiar with,
"and which is called patriotism,
"which was a sentiment of a
force that no one could doubt.
"But part of what appeared
to underlay this mutual sense
"of patriotism was specifically
the devotion displays
"on the battlefield Aboulker,
"his father before in the World War I,
"and so many of their
Algerian Jewish comrades."
So to conclude the unlikely
alliance at the heart
of the November 8th
insurrection between Jews
and frequently anti-semitic
arch conservatives
forces us to rethink
our conventional picture
of who resisted and why
during the second World War
and the Shoal.
Admittedly, part of our misperception
can be laid at the feet
of the post-war writings
of the leading insurgents themselves.
In 1946, when d'Astier submitted a list
of those who participated
in the insurrection,
he depicted himself as
their undisputed leader.
And while he did include José Aboulker,
he explicitly excluded hundreds
of others, mostly Jewish,
who were now part of a Veterans
Association of November 8th,
which he claimed was not to be confused
with the resistance network itself.
Likewise, Aboulker's own memoir
while paying tribute to d'Astier,
spoke about the broader
committee of five in acid terms,
calling them a total failure,
in contrast to the shock troops he had led
and describing the
characteristics of the sincere,
Vichysto-resistant as quote,
honorable and ineffective,
while mocking the group more generally
as by definition, indecisive.
And yet nonetheless, it
was this rebel Alliance
that made the Algiers underground
once arguably the finest hour
of the Vichysto-resistant
and strategically speaking,
the most consequential
Jewish resistance movement
of the second World War.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Ethan for that
was really fascinating.
A story that I did not know much about,
and I'm completely fascinated by it.
And I personally have a lot of questions.
I would encourage everyone in the audience
to please submit questions
using the Q&A function.
We have a bunch mostly from Alice Kaplan,
who is very eager, I know to,
I will ventriloquist her questions,
but first of all, a question
just a little background,
I think might be helpful
for people listening.
So at one point you did
mention that Jews were 10%
of the population of Algiers.
And I think that might surprise people.
So if you could say a little
bit more about the demographics
in Algeria and especially in the cities
and also bringing in Muslims
and the relative population.
- Yeah, so I mean, Algeria
broadly had 6 million,
Muslims at this time, roughly
a million French settlers
and 120,000 or so Jews.
So they are 10% of the French
citizens broadly speaking
in Algeria.
It's so happens that
Algiers is substantially
a European city in many ways by the 1930s.
That is almost 70% of the
inhabitants are either settlers
or Jews.
I think it's about 9% Jewish,
60% settler, 30% Muslims.
So yeah, I mean, the demographics
are such the Jews are,
I mean, a whole another piece of the story
is that Jews are seeking to regain
of course, a position
of equal citizenship,
and they are fighting off
the prospect of Nazi-ism,
but there are also essentially
fighting to recover
what remains a privileged
position in colonial society.
There are extensive debates
about what Jews should do
with regard to that very
question in the period
after the landing, particularly
because it takes so long
for citizenship to be restored.
And there is pressure
from certain Muslim allies
for them to pursue equal
citizenship for all,
rather than simply for themselves.
I'm happy to speak more about those.
- Okay, all right, so here's
one of Alice's question.
So all these Vichy guys had
they ever been in Algeria
before 1942?
Were they thinking about
Algeria and France?
And the antisemites on the
far right on the ground
in Algeria, were they much more
extreme than the Vichy guys?
Were they like sinine level anti-semites?
- Great questions.
So, I mean, most of
these guys had not been
in Algeria before.
I mean, certainly not the
people in the Committee of Five,
they go there.
I mean, in many cases,
they go to already 1940
and like, you can read
conflicting accounts
of some of their motivations.
Like le Mica Dubois is this
super successful businessman.
And some people think that
he was very cynical in his
connections to the Americans
and the Committee of Five,
other people have more
charitable interpretations of him
as a Patriot.
But there's a series of business interests
that lead certain people there.
In some cases people go there
because they are compromised.
d'Astier was in a resistance
network in France proper,
and they escape to Algeria.
But basically, I mean,
I shouldn't say that
they've never been, I can't
say whether they ever visited
Algeria previously, right.
But they have no particular
history or connection
to Algeria.
So, yes, I mean, by and
large, I would say that
these folks are anti-semitism
is less central for them,
than it is for the ultras
of the settlor classes,
which Alice, you know at least
as much about it as I do.
And anti-semitism was really central
to their political culture.
Clearly there's a calculus that goes on.
I try to explain some of
that calculus in my talk,
where it's not that most of these folks
who are the Vichysto-resistant
are necessarily
that positively disposed toward Jews,
but they are more focused
on re-igniting the war
against the Germans.
And we have to keep in mind,
I mean, once we have that
agreement in the summer of 1942,
between d'Astier and Aboulker,
it's explicit that this is
for a finite period of time.
I mean, they can, it's always easier
to work with someone who you
are hardly disagree with,
when you know you're going
to have a chance to hash out
those disagreements later.
So I think that's crucial as well.
I think I answered it.
- Yeah, so I wanted to
probe a little bit more
about the Vichy resistance guys.
And so listening to it,
I couldn't help thinking
not to present ties,
but I couldn't help thinking
about like the Lincoln Project,
and different.
I mean, so what, first
of all, what is really,
I mean, is it about patriotism?
Is it just about like this
idea that how can you side with
the invader, the enemy,
and if so, what does take them so long?
When do they start to resist?
I mean, it's not Milton is not until 1943.
So is that how much of that
is waiting to see which way
the wind was blowing,
which way the war would go?
- They're good questions.
I mean, they're not one group, right?
Those that have been put under
this rubric by historians
in recent years.
So there are those who actually
are very early to the game
in a way that is shocking to us today,
because the way that we've aligned
extreme right of the
thirties with ardent Vichyism
in the forties.
But some of those folks
in the early months
are already saying, "Well,
the Marshal can't resist.
"We gotta do it for him."
And so some of them are
not at all latecomers.
Then you have people like
Milton who evolve in some way,
whether you want to say
that evolution is purely
kinda cynical and self-serving,
or what do you want to
say that they realize.
I mean, there are certainly folks also
who are loyalists to Vichy
without being active resistors,
partly because they assume the Marshall
is acting on their behalf
and they come to conclude
over time that he is not,
and they then become
disillusioned with the regime
and become resistors.
But I think patriotism is the heart of it.
I mean, I think that there
are people who just feel very,
they feel very strongly
against the Germans.
They feel ultimately like
they have to defend France
and that's sort of their
kind of singular focus
in the early months there.
And in a way it maybe isn't
that surprising on reflection
that some of the same extreme
right guys from the thirties
are some of the earliest to want to resist
within the Vichy circles,
because they're used to being active
in kind of radical politics
and their radical politics
has its own kind of ardent
patriotic nationalism attached
to it already before the war.
- Great, okay.
So questions I'm seeing here
about Muslims and about,
so if you could say a little bit more
about Muslim resistance here,
and also a question from
someone in the audience
who wants you to clarify
the use of the term Muslim.
So are you referring to
a mostly Arabized elite
or the Amazi communities or both and yeah.
And if you could say more about their
role in this resistance.
- Yeah, so I mean the role of Muslims
and I would use that term to describe,
just as I would in a
parallel way to the way
that I would use the term Jews.
And I'll talk a little bit
about this in my first book.
I mean, I think there
were and are in many ways
to be in some way connected to Muslimness,
for some people that
is Islam as a religion
and for other people
it's much more cultural,
and that certainly was true in Algeria.
The category of Muslim was racialized
by the French administration,
such that it did not distinguish
between religious practice
or lack of practice at all and
it was all based on descent.
But the reality was a very large spectrum.
So to me, yeah, I mean I,
there were various Muslim political groups
and we can talk a little
bit more about that.
There were very few Muslims
in this resistance movement.
If there were some
resisters during the war,
the two most common avenues
are aligned with the
Algerian Communist Party
and then joining the liberation armies,
as they begin to fight their
way up into France, right?
That's the vast majority
of Muslim Algerians
who joined the resistance in some form,
but there are interesting exceptions.
And the most interesting, I
have a whole chapter about him
in the book is a man named
Muhammad Abdul Azis Kasus,
who is very closely aligned
with a certain movement
in Algeria, led by
(foreign language)
which is sort of a reformist
movement that is increasingly
moving toward nationalism.
And because Kasus is
actually the primary author
of a famous document from during the war,
the manifest of the Algerian People,
which comes out in 1943, in March of 1943.
And in that manifestt, it actually says,
given the repeal of the Crémieux Decree,
Algeria and Muslims are led to wonder
if French citizenship is worth much less
than it would be to be
an Algerian citizen.
So there are certain muscles
like that who actually talk
very actively about the connection
between what goes on
with Jews during the war
and how they are looking for
new political alignments,
including an alliance as I referred to
between Muslims and Jews
to fight for equal rights.
And there are a handful of other
Muslims who are referred to
in various accounts of the
uprising who participated
in different groups, for sure.
But there were also those in
the movement who were worried
about the intensity of access
propaganda Visa de Muslims,
and therefore were hesitant
to invite Muslims to join.
I think, broadly speaking,
this was ultimately a fight
to throw off the Germans,
and for many Jews
to regain their citizenship.
It wasn't a fight that
necessarily clearly implicated
Muslim political activists
for some of the reasons I've already said.
- Okay, great.
So here's a question from David Sorkin.
He says that Vichy's
Jewish statutes of 1941
included exemptions
for Jews who had fought
in either World War or whose
families had been in France
for five generations.
So in what sense could you say
that the monarchist reactionary figures
in the uprising are
actually acting in line with
a certain understanding of Vichy policy?
- Yeah, great question as
usual, thank you, David.
So yeah, I mean, I actually
thought of mentioning that.
Clearly there's a broader
way in which military service
is honored by Vichy, including
to a significant extent
for Jews.
You have all these petitions
to Vichy that many of us
have seen from right after
the first of Jewish statute
where people say, "My
husband or my father served
"in World War I and you should
make an exception for him."
Now, while most of those are not honored,
it's a reflection partly
already of the cultural ethos
around wartime service.
And then as David said, there
are these exemptions in 1941.
So yeah, I mean, I think
that it does reflect that.
I think, one of the other
things I talk about in the book
is that a kind of effort to regain manhood
is one of the things that goes
on in this Jewish insurgency.
And you have, you saw
briefly the images there,
you have a boxing ring as the
center for the largest force
within the insurgency.
You have like famous boxers
coming through there,
you have fencing, which,
however strange it may seem to us today
was very strongly associated
with European manhood
at this time.
And Jews had been
disproportionately participating
in fencing for decades.
Get a lot of fencing
competitions, had Jewish finalists
who were in the fencing
competitions in Algeria,
in the early 40s, despite the
opposition of anti-Semites.
She had all of this sort
of hyper masculine energy
and many of these people were veterans,
as I said of the campaign in 1940.
So in some ways I think all
of this is kind of connected
that their efforts to
reclaim masculinity comes
partly in the form of
joining a resistance group.
And they are more palatable
to certain rightists
because of the fact that they connect to,
military background, military culture.
- So to follow up on that
question, there's all this,
you're describing this
sort of masculine energy,
it's this story about reclaiming
mass masculine identity,
but what about women in
these resistance groups?
You mentioned Colette, the
sister of José, I think,
but are, were there other women involved?
- There were other women
and Colette is fascinating
and I'm actually, I'm
starting the book with Colette
because she wrote a five
volume memoir of her childhood.
She later became a very
kind of illustrious healer
through psychological work in Israel.
And so she was a deeply spiritual person
and that's part of what
punctuates her memoir,
but she also shows how
much she felt the burden
of her family's history.
I didn't have time to get into it here,
but her family had this
kind of rabbinic dynasty
in its history.
It had, then all these people who had been
the first Jew to practice
medicine and Algiers,
people who were enormously successful
in secular colonial society.
And so she hears things from family
and she says things like,
"I understood that I would
be the one in my generation
"to help save the Jewish people,
maybe to save the world."
So she's fascinating.
And she plays a really important role.
I mean, her father also describes
how she kept everything
together in the house,
when everything's buzzing
and there's a million people
coming through and she's basically
keeping all the trains running.
There are, and there
are several other women
who maybe we would say have
comparable roles of the wife,
(foreign language)
She like, there's accounts
about how she's making food
for all of these people on
the night of the uprising.
And she's hiding guns in
different places in the house.
It's clearly a small number
of women who participate
and we even have an account of a one
altercation a little bit on
the night of the uprising,
where certain male resisters
don't want women taking part,
which I think reinforces the sense
of a kind of hyper masculine
identity for certain segments.
But there were women who
played important roles,
certainly particularly Colette Aboulker.
- Great, okay.
Another question from Alice Kaplin,
she's wondering what you have to say about
the reluctance of the allies
to cancel the abrogation
of the Crémieux Decree.
So the Jews had to wait for months
to get their citizenship back.
How do we explain that?
Is that American anti-semitism at work
or is it the fault of the French, what?
- Well, I mean, it's a complex story.
I think the Americans were persuaded
and Robert Murphy writes
about this in his memoir
in ways that are frankly
embarrassing at this point.
But he felt very strongly that,
the Americans were very worried
that there would be a lot of Muslim anger
if Jewish citizenship was restored.
There is intense lobbying from
the American Jewish community
that takes place
and that ultimately has
a significant impact.
And people are miffed and Murphy says,
they didn't understand how
everything was so different
in North Africa.
North African Jews are different,
North African society is different.
But there definitely were
people were persuaded that
Jewish-Muslim enmity was primordial
and that if Jews were given
back their citizenship,
despite the fact that then
Jews produced letters, right,
from leading Muslim city
counselors and figures saying,
"We didn't have any joy about the
abrogation of the Crémieux Decree
and that that's not something
we celebrated at all.
So but, so that's clearly a
factor then you I think have
folks who never, I mean, you
have a significant segment
of Algerian colonial society
that had been campaigning
for the abrogation of
Crémieux Decree for 70 years.
And so was deeply invested in that.
And to some extent of
people like Henri Giraud,
who's the governor general
for awhile after the landing.
They are kind of responding to
the pressure from those folks
and some of those folks.
And some of the other Vichy
officials are also saying,
there'll be a civil war between
the Jews and the Muslims.
So there's a lot of that.
But I also think that
the story I told today,
is an important ingredient.
That is the Vichysto-resistant,
are basically,
like the slates wiped
clean in November, 1942.
They and many of their supporters,
wanna kind of rechart what
colonial Algeria looks like.
Jews are fighting for a different
vision of colonial Algeria
that aligns with their Republican Judaism.
And so it's not shocking in that way
that given that they had
no ideological consensus
and that these two
visions were so opposed,
it's not shocking that it
took effectively months
to hash that out.
And it's inseparable from the struggle
between the Jihadist forces
and the godless forces
in Algeria in 1943.
- Great, okay, I'm going to
ask a selfish question here
and I'd like to,
yeah, thank you for mentioning my book
and I, so I was very interested,
I'm very interested in how
anti-Semitism becomes a key part
of right wing ideology in France.
And so part of what I was
interested in was looking at
a possible origin point for that
or one of the possible origin points.
But we know that like something,
we normally think of World War
II is sort of the culmination
of that right.
Vichy is the culmination, it's
the revenge on for Dreyfus.
And they're able to enact,
to really make antisemitism
a part of state policy.
But you're kind of giving
this other possible other
way to see it.
And then it, maybe it's a culmination,
but it's also things go over the hill
and it's maybe also the end
or an end point for that.
I don't know, how do you see that in?
'Cause it's true that
anti-semitism stops being a kind of
the key part of right wing
ideology after World War II,
partly because it's discredited by Hitler,
but maybe there's also
something else going on too.
- Well, I mean,
so I'm still learning
a lot about monarchists
and 20th century France an
understudied subject for sure.
But what I can, what I've gathered is,
you have the Action française,
which is this Neo-monachist organization,
but of course they attract
many folks who are not
monarchists per se, not the
d'Astier style of monarchist,
where like your father
and your grandfather,
and your great-grandfather were
monarchist for generations,
but people who are basically
interested in right wing radical politics.
And Charles Maurras is
arguably the most influential,
right-wing radical thinker
in 20th century, France.
So that's like a different
brand of monarchism,
but it becomes discredited effectively
by a lot of the traditional monarchists
by the 20s and 30s, right.
There were announced by the
Holy See, I think in 1927,
and then they're renounced by
(foreign language)
in the mid 30s.
And we should point out, I mean,
it's a complicated history,
but because of the
Bourbons, the legitimists,
who are traditionally the
more conservative ones,
were stuck as it were with a
Spanish line from the 1880s,
(foreign language)
becomes the defacto pretender
kind of for everybody,
even though he's from
the only on East branch.
But perhaps a consequence
of that is that the
(foreign language)
is always more moderate and up,
he ends up sort of pushing things
in a more moderate direction.
Yeah, I mean, I think as anti-semitism,
I think we could say that as anti-semitism
becomes radicalized in
the 30s and early 40s,
it becomes much more uncomfortable
for certain monarchists
who are more traditionalist.
- Yeah, okay, good,
that's super interesting.
Okay, we're almost out of time,
but I wanted to ask one
other question about
why more Algerian Jews who were
expelled from their schools
in 1940, faced all these
anti-semitic prosecutions.
Why didn't more aside
with the FLN in the 50s.
What do you think?
How do you explain that?
- Great question, right.
It's a sort of a $64,000
question about Algerian history.
Yeah, I mean, I think that in some ways
there's a parallel between, if you will,
1900 in the French main land
where the Dreyfus Affair
is almost forgotten and seen
as, okay the Republic works,
eventually Dreyfus was
pardoned and then of course
he was exonerated 1906.
There's a parallel in some
ways between that and 1945
in Algeria.
I mean, to some extent in
the French mainland as well,
but basically the Vichy
years are in a way,
I mean, they're not entirely forgotten.
And so you have the attempt
of the FLN during the 50s
repeatedly to invoke
the Vichy years and say,
the same people who are
advocating for colonialism
are the ones who, took
away your citizenship
and treated you horribly then
and we were your, we were
in solidarity with you.
But in a certain way, it's
like the Jews basically just,
kind of wanna paper that over
and think that the real France,
was the France that restored their rights.
And they just, they also see
themselves, they're articulate,
they see themselves as so
Frenchified by the 50s,
that in a way it's almost
like there's no going back.
- So they buy into the
godless myth in a sense
and then yeah.
- You saying of the resistors?
- No, no, no the post-war Gaullist myth,
yes, that everyone had
resisted that that wasn't
the real France that had
done this to them and---
- Yeah, but I think also they just,
they see themselves as products
of a process of successful
emancipation and Frenchification
and they see Muslims as like
on the same track they hope,
just several steps behind.
And they kinda carry that
vision through to the end.
- All right, well, we are
unfortunately out of time,
but I wanna thank you for
this really enlightening
and just fascinating presentation
and thanks for sharing it
and co-hosting this event with us.
So we're really looking
forward to the book.
So I know everyone else is
applauding at home but---
- Thanks for all the questions.
- Yeah.